and we are logging the moderator is
logging into the conference call so that
we can ask questions as
well it's good I'm glad we have this
technology because
otherwise Terrible
Things 45 minutes that's the
goal what I want you to do is stand up
and say thank you ladies and Gentlemen
please I'm okay very good all
right good that's what I that's what I
need you to
do five that would be that would be
great that would be great theoretically
I ought to know
time I did and I'm prepared to skip over
some other
slides so excellent
I can read the crowd I can already see
that this crowd understands this so I'm
going to skip over the first half we'll
be out of here in no
time so the remote people can hear me I
have uh gotten texts from them which is
excellent uh we are not part of the
conference call yet but uh they can see
and hear me so I could get started
potentially Lynn will be jumping in here
and putting us on the conference call
but that would just be a little more
divided attention
yes okay which is the topic today um
we're all very proud that James actually
known as zephy M um is defending his uh
PhD dissertation today and uh welcome
the family friends and all the
supporters and the cookies too um zephy
has been with us uh Misha Pavel and I
knew him um when he first came to
Portland and was helping on a variety of
projects from all kinds of neuros
pychological tests to um programming
games with spry learning um we have
Payton Bissell here with uh representing
those days it's a long history here but
um the time has come for zephy to uh
discuss a completely new model of
attention divided attention in
particular and um looking forward to
this as a heads up we will give him
about 45 minutes
to present his work and um allow the
audience then to ask questions at the
end then we will ask you to gracefully
leave because the rest of the committee
will Grill him very severely so um and
and we'll um release him
afterwards what time is the class yeah I
think I think we're going to go upstairs
and okay we'll have to journ to another
we'll all have to move out of here at
4:00
thank you for the heads up on that
so yeah okay we're ready to go thank you
zy thank you
Holly I am excited that was a that was a
wonderful introduction forgotten my
entire talk um this is great I Lyn go
ahead they can handle a little divided
attention I'm sure so um as Holly
mentioned uh this is my dissertation
work it's been a long time coming I'm
super excited to talk to you about it um
and it's on divided attention
particularly how we can understand that
in its relation to aging and cognition
um through unobtrusive continuous
measures just to start off this is where
we're going these are the points that
you ought to look at and say wow that's
pretty cool or at least I look at them
and say that um these are the major
contributions of this work the first
first is divided attention can be
measured through measuring an
interaction in a dual task test now some
of you who know what that is might think
oh yeah that's makes a lot of sense and
others of you might not know what that
is that's totally fine we'll be going
over it but it's it's a pretty cool uh
Discovery we've also enhanced one of the
standard tests of divided attention um
by measuring an interaction and uh and
the really cool stuff in terms of
applying this to uh the the world and
and and specifically gerontology
allowing people to age in place is that
we can actually measure the same sort of
thing uh through a cognitive computer
game but it's going to take us a little
while to get there so we do have a road
map first we overview motivation and
then I'm going to be talking about the
standard test that we use which is the
useful field of view test or ufov the
game that we use which is called 21
tally and then how we enhanced these to
sort of put them into the lab and and
actually do these tests then the pilot
study and the main
study in terms of the
motivation all of you know this but but
you might not know just how bad it is
cognitive decline is incredibly
expensive both in terms of dollars and
particularly in terms of time uh you can
read these for yourselves and and be a
gas as I am I'm just going to emphasize
this one down here 15 million unpaid
caregivers that's friends family who are
spending their time which could be used
elsewise in in potentially you know
societally productive ways um to care
for people with cognitive decline and
this is right now this is pre of the 76
million baby boomers going into serious
cognitive decline time this is only
going to go up a lot really soon so we
need to find some way to keep these
people active to keep them in their
homes to allow them to age in place
otherwise this is all our country is
going to do and that's pretty scary one
of the best ways that we can do this I
argue is through unobtrusive continuous
inhome monitoring now before we get into
what exactly that is and why it's better
let's talk about the way that people are
uh tested for cognitive decline and
Alzheimer's disease right now right now
you come into the lab and uh you go
through a battery of neuropsychological
tests and you get a diagnosis you have
Alzheimer's you don't have Alzheimer's
you have mild cognitive impairment now
that's fine for diagnosing something
like a broken
leg it's not very good for diagnosing
something like cognitive decline which
first of all happens
over a very long time potentially starts
when you're 20 years old and continues
on and it's really bad for something
like cognitive decline where one of the
Prime characteristics of it is that it
gets more variable as you you on so when
you go into the neuropsychologist office
they have no idea whether you're having
a good day a bad day or a standard day
you can't compare it to your own
Baseline because they have no idea what
your Baseline is they don't know what
your variabil your day-to-day
variability is your week to week
variability so they have no idea what
your decline is and when you're
comparing to some sort of National
Standard they don't know uh whether you
started out as a genius or a mediocre
level or less than that in terms of your
cognitive ability
so it's a bit of a
problem now if you were to uh have a
measurement that was taken from your
your daily life or something that you
liked to do on a daily or weekly basis
this would be more of a continuous
measure and that would allow you to
measure these sorts of Trends and If
This Were unobtrusive If This Were
something that you didn't have to go out
of your way to do that would be
excellent it would solve a lot of these
problems it would allow you to compare
to your own Baseline take uh data from
activities that are already happening
and get these Trend data that are really
important in addition potentially you
would not have to have a one-on-one uh
expensive highly trained person uh
looking at your data and no one else's
data during that you know hour or two
hours of your of your battery so it may
be cost effective however this is not a
silver bullet or anything like that
there are cons to this these are noisy
data if you design a test to
specifically talk about uh for instance
divided attention that test likely
measures divided attention whereas if
you were taking it from for instance a
cognitive computer game there might be
other things going on so it's noisy uh
there are initial setup costs because
you go into a home no home is exactly
like any other home and there are
obviously privacy and security concerns
I'm not going to talk about any of that
right
now
spite just to say that I think this is
the wave of the future in terms of
monitoring cognition and one of the best
ways that I think we can monitor
cognition in this unobtrusive continuous
way is through cognitive computer games
now you may have seen this slide before
I've certainly talked about it a few
times since we developed these games in
2006 or so um these games have been
through many pilot tests and usability
tests and the one that I'm particularly
going to be talking about now is this 21
tally game and the reason that is is
that divided attention which this game
is designed to measure is one of the
first uh cognitive problems to decline
when you start to cognitively decline
and that makes it a very important thing
to measure if you're trying to catch
when someone starts a cognitively cline
and it also is one of the major skills
that you need to interact with our
increasingly diverse and self phones
going off and everything happening at
once environment so it's an important
skill that we need to keep as we age and
it's also a scill that unfortunately
declines fairly quickly as we age so
what is attention very broadly we could
think of attention as something uh that
uh as a cognitive skill where you pay
attention to relevant stimuli in pursuit
of some goal and often you have to
ignore some distractors right in order
to pursue this goal now divided
attention same sort of thing except that
you have multiple stimuli that you need
to pay attention to and I love this
definition that I got uh from Misha
which says it's a skill which allows
attention to multiple simultaneous
stimuli required to achieve some goal
perfect right and if you have heard
about divided attention before you've
probably heard about it in the context
of driving and driving and texting and
that sort of thing and the reason why is
that driving is already an intensely
divided intention uh using skill you
have to pay attention to all many things
that are happening you have to pay
attention to the stop lights and the
stop signs and other cars and who's
merging as well as the radio and the air
conditioning and who's talking to you at
the same time so as soon as you are
adding another device like text or or
food or something like that then your
attention is stretched much thinner you
are adding more Division and you may
have some sort of problem
so that's the context that many people
have talked about in terms of divided
attention so this brings us to our
research question which is can we
accurately measure divided attention
using some sort of naturalistic gameplay
in a clinically meaningful way can we
measure this using a game can we measure
it at all using a test that's what we're
going to explore in order to do that we
need to have some sort of a standard
test of divided attention and the test
that correlates best with driving
ability is the useful field of view test
and this is the standard useful field of
view test the second part of the of the
useful field of view test and um in it
you have an icon uh either a car or a
truck that appears in the center of your
field of view and you have another icon
a car that appears somewhere on the
periphery of your field of view and
these flash up for a fairly brief amount
of time something like that okay that
was pretty fast did you see it now now
the looking for it you ought to be able
to look at this and answer a couple
questions there it is and the questions
are what was in the center was it a car
or a truck and where was the thing on
the periphery so you get asked was this
a car or a truck I don't remember now I
think it was a car and where was it on
the periphery in one of these eight
locations I think it was up in the upper
right there and that is the useful field
of view test and if you get these
questions right pardon me then um the
dur duration of the stimulus decreases
and if you get them wrong the duration
increases so it it goes in a staircase
algorithm to find your 75% accuracy
threshold duration and you'll hear me
refer to that over and over in this test
this is an important number you as the
threshold duration the 75% accuracy
duration that sort of thing and the
reason is that this is your score on the
use of field of view right and so it
goes shorter longer shorter longer
shorter longer shorter longer until you
get to approximately 75% and then you
stop and you get this score that's your
threshold score now there are a couple
of problems with this
test some of them are problems with a
test as a test such as these icons are
arbitrary they're very close together
they're they're they're odd they also
happen to be proprietary and this test
is in fact commercial it costs money to
take and that may be why they were
created in this particular particular
way but there are also only two of them
and so when you're choosing in the
center even if you had your eyes closed
for the entire duration you got a 50%
guess rate that's just odd why would you
make a test like that when you're trying
to measure the difference in in in two
different tasks divided attention right
you're doing two things at once well if
one of them has a 50% gas rate that's
seems strange but I really want to focus
on this last problem which is the
problem of this test as a test of
divided attention the only thing that
you change in terms of changing uh the
difficulty of these tasks is the
duration of the stimulus that means that
both of the difficulties are changing at
the same time you're never changing one
without changing the other so you can't
really tell what the difficulty of one
task changing would do to your
performance on the other task which was
really what you would want to know in
terms of dividing your attention all you
really know in this task is well you do
know something something about divided
attention for instance if I were taking
this test and you were taking this test
and and your ability to pay attention to
two things at once was much better than
mine you probably would get a better
score on this test than I would however
it's conflated with this idea of speed
of processing because what if my ability
to take in this image and process it in
my brain coded as something and spit it
back out as some sort of a solution I
know where this was and what this was is
much faster than yours well then I would
do better on this test even if I weren't
very good at doing two things at once so
it's measuring speed of processing as
well as divided attention and that's a
problem because these are potentially
quite different uh neurological
processes so we really want to separate
those out which brings us to specific G
number one which is basically can we
separate those out we would like to we
would like to build some sort of a model
of divided attention that differentiates
divided attention from speed processing
and particularly develop some sort sort
of a test that specifically tests
divided attention because that's what we
want to know about we don't really want
to know about speed of processing
so let's talk about what divided
attention might look like in order to
sort of visualize why we should be
measur what we should be measuring and
and why we should be doing the tests
that we do so if you just imagine for a
moment that your brain is a computer and
it has some parallel processors like
this you throw in a problem and spits
out a solution that's very nice if you
have some sort of an easy task maybe
you're only using a couple of these
processors at once no problem and if you
have a medium task still you can handle
it it's not a problem but if you have a
hard task maybe you're using up all your
processors so in order to deal with this
task you have a couple of issu uh a
couple of choices and it comes uh down
to what we call the speed accuracy
trade-off you can either cut off that
solution before you're really done
marinating on it in which case your
accuracy is going to go down or you
extend it a little bit you take a little
bit more time in order to deal with this
problem and then you have a an accurate
solution and so that's going to show up
in our threshold value if we're keeping
the accuracy the same 75% accuracy it's
going to take you longer to get there so
your score is going to be longer it
turns out this applies in exactly the
same way div added attention doing two
easy tasks if you can handle it no
problem as soon as you're doing two
medium tasks and especially two hard
tasks tasks one task is going to start
to interfere with the other a lot more
and that's what we're measuring that's
what we want to measure and in terms
of measuring this in the lab if you were
to think about those of you who who are
of a mathematical bent if you were to
think about what would it look like to
measure something where one task the
difficulty increasing here is
interfering with my performance on this
other task that's an
interaction so if we were to measure if
we were to map I should say graph task
one going from easy all the way up to
hard here and we were to keep the other
task easy maybe you're able to handle
that maybe it gets a little bit maybe
your threshold value gets a little bit
longer but not particularly longer but
if you had an interaction as you
increase the difficulty of the other
task it's this slope is going to
increase and increase and that's what an
interaction looks like that's what we're
trying to measure here okay so that's
our idea of divided attention so how are
we going to get there well in terms of
this test say the useful field of view
test and it'll you'll see It'll apply as
well to this 21 tally game we have two
tasks and we need to be able to
accurately change the difficulty of both
of those subtasks right the central
subtask where you're asking what is in
the center and the peripheral subtask
where you're asking where is this thing
on the periphery we need to be able to
to change those difficulty levels in
such a way that we get a measurable
response so when it gets harder you're
threshold value gets longer and when it
gets easier your threshold value gets
less easy so in order to do this we had
a pilot study this was a convenient
sample of 10 people um it was there were
were fairly uh large age range and and
many of the people who took this were
here are here and I appreciate your
help pardon me and basically they came
into the lab did the useful Field view
did the 21 tally experiment and then uh
we determined whether our attempted
changes on each of these subtasks
actually had a measurable effect on
their threshold value I want to tell you
what we came up with first of
all changes to the useful field of
view
we got rid of these proprietary shapes
for reasons we don't have any prary
shapes in our in our new test but also
just so that we would have a normal very
recognizable shapes just circles and
Crosses along the periphery and then in
the center just uh English letters and
we had all English speakers all language
literate people very recognizable these
letters are very recognizable and we
used these eight specifically many
people ask me why those eight
specifically well we looked in the
literature and found that these were uh
uh not the least confusable but an equal
confusability with each other in this
particular font of uh Capital uh
helvetica and I'll just show this uh
this is the confusability table uh they
were given many more than 100 times but
it's been normalized to 100 and you'll
see each one was only confused with each
other one less than five times except
for I which was contes with P 7% of the
time so around the same amount of times
and wanted to have eight so that we
would have a a reasonable range of
things that you couldn't just guess
right not just
two but we also need to change the
subtask effectively change the
difficulty of the subtask I should say
so what the way we did that was on the
periphery rather than just having uh a
luminance test like you have in the in
the uh in the standard use of field of
view that is all you have to do is see
on the periphery something white as
opposed to all of the darkness you
actually have to have uh distractors in
each of the other locations so rather
and and equal luminance distractors I
should say so the target is a circle
with a cross in it and the distractors
are circles with x's in them and you
have to find the cross right so that's
our peripheral task and then we can
change the difficulty simply by
increasing or decreasing the number of
distractors which has a large literature
that says that this will in fact ch
change the difficulty and it it shows
that our our findings did did show that
as well which is nice and in the center
we also wanted to have a measurable
thing that we could change in a
particular way to have a measurable
effect so what we did was blur these
letters okay so we could blur them by
certain number of pixels I believe this
is zero five and 10 pixels of blur after
that it gets really hard to tell what it
is and um and so that's how we changed
the central task so if you were to look
at the absolute easiest of the
sets of conditions for the subtasks to
the very hardest you'll notice there's
no blur here only four um things on the
periphery three distractors and one
target versus a lot of blur and 11
distractors and one Target on the
periphery this is a very hard task as
you can see if that were to flash up 500
milliseconds 600 milliseconds you could
do it but it takes some practice in and
a lot of concentration whereas this one
is pretty equivalent to the standard
test flashes up you can find it in 50 to
100 milliseconds without any
trouble pardon me but in order to have
some sort of an application I know this
is the the thing you've all been waiting
for and I've been waiting to tell you
about it we need to have some sort of a
computer
game uh equivalent to it something that
someone will do because people are not
going to take this enhanced useful field
of view test every day for the rest of
their
lives some of our elders said that they
would because they're very concerned
about their their cognition but I don't
want to do that I would rather play
computer games so um we want to
translate this into something that
people will do either are doing now or
or will do and the way that we did that
is this 21 tally
game now this can be thought of as
blackjack in two Dimensions if you've
ever played blackjack you know that
you're looking for 21 and you're trying
not to go over 21 anything under 21
you're fine you're not not good you're
not bad but 21 you're golden over 21
that's considered a bust and that's bad
and what you're trying to do in this
game you have 4x4 grid 16 places to play
this card like so and you're trying to
get 21 in the rows or the columns at the
same time so if you were to play like so
I'll just play until uh we get to an
interesting play that would have a would
have a
21 so here so I can see if I were to
play the nine plus 12 in in that row
there then I will get 21 so I'm going to
put it
here but I ended up busting in the
column see so this is the idea if you
are paying attention only to one
dimension at a time then you will not
perform as well as someone who is paying
attention to both dimensions at once
hence the divided attention aspect of
this
game now there are a couple of problems
with this in terms of a lab setting and
basically they are that this game was
designed to be a game in someone's home
over a long period of time a year or two
years or there it's in a fiveyear study
now this is not uh intended to be in a
lab setting where someone comes in for
an hour or two and plays this game the
problem is that each of the divided
attention intensive uh uh setting boards
are relatively few and far between you
saw it took me nine or 10 plays to get
to something where I even potentially
could have done a bust and a 21 at the
same time so what we need to do is
redesign for the lab uh oh and also I
should mention uh one of our summer
interns did some really excellent work
saying that there are uh as you might
expect different cognitive loads for
different numbers of cards and Open
Spaces on the board so we need to have
we need to equalize that out we don't
want to have that be part of our
difficulty which brings us to specific
game number two which is how can we make
this game into something that we can
clinically validate or or have some sort
of a predictive power in terms of
measuring divided attention and the way
in which we did this is to make the 21
tally puzzle and this is basically each
board is no longer contiguous you get
one board you get to play once on it and
then you get a completely new board okay
each board has eight open spaces and
eight cards each board has only one best
place to play okay so if you look at
this one your next card is the king you
can see that this is going to bust
everywhere except in the bottom right
there's only one best place to play and
also it gives us an ability to change
the difficulty level on each of the two
Dimensions which is important right
because we need to be able to do that in
order to measure divided attention so
the way we change the difficulty level
pardon me is to
say on each of the two Dimensions how
many different potential outcomes are
there right in terms of bust 21 or
neither of those right so it could be
anything from one to three and on this
you can see there are two in each one in
each one you can either Bust or not bust
right and there's only one best place to
play where you can not bust on both the
final thing that we did to make it more
time pressure much more much more like
the useful field of view is that we only
allowed them to see the stimulus for a
certain amount of time and then the
cards turn over okay so you can still
respond you can still say okay this is
where I should play bottom right hand
corner or if you are not sure than
perhaps somewhere else and then we know
which one you got wrong but we only get
to see it for a certain amount of time
just like the years of field of view so
that's how we ended up uh dealing with
the 21 tally making it into more of a
lab
test so let's talk about the main study
there are two things we're looking for
here first first of all is the
interaction between these difficulties
significant because if it is significant
then that for that particular person
then we can measure their divided
attention remember the interaction is
our our proxy for a measure of divided
attention because if you have a large
interaction then
your it's basically a measure of your
inability to use your divided attention
right if you have a large interaction
then your ability to use divided
attention has been maxed out and you can
no longer uh deal with these the
difficulties of these two tasks at
once and if there is a significant
interaction then does the magnitude of
that interaction uh translate does it
does it equate between 21 tally and use
and our enhanced useful field of view
because if it does then we're measuring
the same thing and if we're measuring
the same thing and we're measuring
devided attention then we're
golden so let's talk about what we did
we brought 50 people
in huge age range range we tried to uh
uh essentially get them in the um into
uh a roughly equivalent number of um
people in each uh age group each
category of of age each person we asked
that they had played a computer game in
the last year um this was basically for
as a screening purpose we wanted people
who had the familiarity with the
computer and the mouse that they could
actually take these tests and also we
wanted to be testing on people who would
actually benefit from these procedures
if you're if you're not ever going to
play a computer game then perhaps these
tests this this this work may not apply
to you um this also was a convenience
sample from around the Portland area as
you might expect they're overwhelmingly
white very high education level um we
did ask that people have no uncorrect
division problems this meant something
different to our elders than it meant to
me I meant that you would have Vision
corrected to to 2020 and they said I
absolutely have a corrected Vision not
to 2020 though so we had a few of our
elders who had some vision problems but
we uh we we left them in because we l
them
all so basically the protocol was very
similar to the pilot study um we brought
people in we had them uh go through uh
an instruction period which involved
demos and practice on each of the tests
the tasks the 21 and use of field of
view and then they did the enhanced use
of field of view um also did the
standard uh useful field of view so we
could get some sort of a comparison
there and one uh trial set of each of
the sets of conditions for each of the
tasks the enhanced use of fueld view and
the 21 tally CL so the sets of
conditions you'll remember are the
different difficulty levels of the
subtasks so for instance one set of
condition would be easy Central subtask
and and hard peripheral subtask that' be
one set of
conditions now when
we're we're trying to measure these
things what we really want to get at is
the underlying internal neural
processes uh but we can't measure those
directly we don't we don't have the IRB
approval to measure those
directly uh but uh but we so all we can
measure is behavior right but this
behavior is indicative of an internal uh
neural process and there are a couple
processes that I want to focus on
because we saw both of them and I'll be
talking about that and one of them is is
a parallel process this is what we
talked about before with parallel
processors right and this is you're
doing both of these things at the same
time and so the only thing that is
affecting our measurement of your
threshold value is whichever one takes
longer you're doing both of these at the
same time you stop doing the shorter one
for instance in this case the central
task
you were done with that but you're still
working on the peripheral one well the
only thing that we can measure here is
the peripheral one because all we know
is your sort of group threshold value
now if you contract that with a Serial
process this would be you're doing one
task you finish that task and you do the
other task and in this in this case
there are uh both of the both of the
difficulty levels contribute to the
overall threshold value right and there
could be any number of mixed you know
from one to the other but we're not
going to talk about those because it
would be very hard to sort of tease out
where one stopped and the other one
began but we are going to talk about
parallel and serial and if you were
talking about the mathematical uh
representation of these as you might
expect the parallel model is based on
the maximum whichever one takes longer
the serial model is is an additive model
based on both of the threshold values
okay now what what these look like in
terms of our graph is fairly uh distinct
these two these two models look fairly
distinct so if you were to measure again
the one of the subtasks in this case the
central subtask going from easy medium
and hard the easy peripheral value might
be there there and there so really we're
looking at a straight line because
there's no uh increase in the difficulty
in the in the threshold measured based
on increasing the central difficulty
there may be in this case there is an
increase in the threshold as you
increase the peripheral difficulty right
so there's only one that's really
affecting if you were to measure it the
other way with the peripheral difficulty
down here then you would see an increase
in all three of these right these are
the same same data from the same person
this is toy data of course um but the
important part is if you were to for
instance take a oneway Anova of this
easy peripheral uh this this this this
easy task keeping this task easy this P
value would be greater than 0.5 and this
P value would be less than 05 what that
means is there's no difference between
these values statistically speaking and
there is a statistical difference
between these values because one of the
tasks is in fact affecting the overall
threshold value and the other one isn't
now this is pretty interesting because
we have actual data that looks exactly
like that so that's
fun one thing that you would need to
know that these were uh were the same of
course the P value tells you because
it's greater than Alpha of 05 but but
the box plots let you know that you know
these median values are essentially no
different statistically and if you were
to add the other values in it gets a lot
more complicated um this one also has no
interaction but the reason we don't
Focus on the hard values is because this
could very well have an interaction in
which case this hard might go up to the
sky right but this easy one
stays equivalent with a P value greater
than uh 05 and if you map again this is
the same data same data just mapped this
way instead of this way right then you
can see all three of them just go up
nicely like that as the peripheral
difficulty increases their threshold
value increases so this is a person who
parallel processing and the peripheral
value the peripheral task subtask is
taking longer than the central
subtask now I'd like to contrast that
with the serial value the serial case
this is again a toy example I don't
really need to show it to you but in
each case they increase because both of
the tasks difficulties are uh involved
in the eventual threshold and we also
have data that uh that show this sort of
a of an underlying process process a
Serial underlying process so the P
values in both directions I only have to
show you one because they look quite
similar are less than 05 quite a bit
less in fact so these are are the the uh
median values are
different the other thing that we really
want to focus on here and
uh is the interaction term right that's
what we really want to get at and it
turns out that both of these processes
for almost both of these models I should
say for almost every one fit better with
an interaction term and that's really
great because that means that we can
actually compare your interaction term
magnitude and say okay you have better
more of an interaction and therefore
worse divided attention than this person
who has a smaller interaction therefore
a better divided attention they're able
to divide their attention and deal with
both of these tasks at once and some of
these are really dramatic this is not
the same person I showed you before but
it's a person who has also has no
interaction really you can see the
bottom and the top fairly flat
right contrast with this where you know
the the uh the easy line down here is
fairly flat but the but the uh the slope
just increases dramatically as you talk
about getting medium and then hard this
hard value especially the hard hard
value they're ability to deal with two
hard tasks at once both of these tasks
are interfering with the other one
causing this threshold value to just
Skyrocket excellent
thanks so I'm just going to switch gears
here just for a moment and say that uh
the other thing that you really want to
look at in terms of a test like this is
how does it me how does it measure up to
the standard test and I think this is
really interesting in order to do that
you're going to need a test retest
uh protocol and luckily we did take the
standard test a number of times so that
we can give you so you have a a
correlation value when you test retest
on the standard test of about 76 and
that is in line with the uh with the
literature and if you compare the
standard score to the enhanced ufov easy
easy you have an equivalently high
Pearson's R now the interesting part
about this is that the easy easy value
is represents the least amount of
interference that we would have tested
between one task and the other both of
them are very easy right and that means
it's the closest that we can get to
measuring just your speed of processing
and this is our highest
correlation with the standard test now
that suggests that at least in this
population the standard test is really
measuring speed of processing and not
really measuring divided attention I'm
skip over a few things here just to jump
to this which really puts that into
perspective you can see this is the
enhanced ufov and all of these are uh
correlations with the standard ufov and
the the uh easy easy is very high in the
and the and the um and the hard heart is
very low so when you talk about having a
large interference or measuring some
sort of divided attention your
correlation with the standard test is
very low now I think that that
is interesting and should be looked into
more we haven't looked into it more but
but it should
be
and the grand finale uh the the thing
that I think is really great is the
comparison between the magnitude of the
interaction values in measuring 21 tally
and the enhanced ufov we have a very
high correlation value now those of you
who know how to calculate correlations
are looking at this and saying well you
do
but it's really because you have this
one guy who's crazy out here and that's
true U but if you take him out you still
have about a point8 but that's not what
I want to talk about what I want to talk
about is when you break it down by age
group it looks really like what you
would expect which is which is nice the
75% or or rather the 75 plus people are
higher than the rest and and pretty much
everybody else it's just down in this
little Clump down here and if we were to
zoom in then you can see that again you
have some 60s you know 60 plus some 50
plus but pretty much everybody lower
than 50 is down in this little Clump
right here now although I will say
especially there's this x right here and
if I zoom in again I think you'll be
able to see it this guy is uh I believe
72 and doing just as well
as any of the under 40s and that's
exactly what we would expect expect to
see uh from the literature and and
should be hardening really which is that
the you know as you
age uh your divided attention your your
cognition may not decline but your
average as a group your your variability
gets much bigger so the the group
average gets much much worse and this
really speaks to the problem that I was
talking about before because we're right
now we're comparing all these neuros
pychological tests to the group average
that's not not appropriate for this guy
at all right and um so that's fun it
should look this way it does look this
way I I'm happy about that you can be
happy or not but you should be should so
we have a lot of cool data here um I've
worked on it for a while I think it
deserves to be worked on for a while
more I'm excited about the future
directions we could go with this this
deserves a longitudinal study for some
reason they don't let grad students do a
longal study and um from where I'm
standing right now now thank
you
uh because I would have jumped on it and
it would have been a mistake um the the
standard US field of view as I mentioned
is really was designed as a test of
driving ability right an off-road
driving test so I would like to know how
our test correlates with with driving
ability I would love to have you know
some a simulated or even an onroad test
to see because if our easy easy is
correlating with driving ability is is
really correlating with driving ability
and our hard heart isn't or for instance
our interaction measure isn't then that
suggests that in terms of the driving
tests that we have what's really the
most important is speed of processing
and not divided attention and that's
interesting I don't think that we have
explored that and certainly I don't have
the data to explore it here but I'd like
to um the useful field of view test has
been shown to be remediative in terms of
bringing back your your uh your uh
divided attention ability I'd love to
know if our tests or our games do that
and frankly our current data we have a
lot more to look at that we simply
didn't have time to look at it in
conclusion I believe you can measure at
least in this in this sample uh divided
attention by measuring the interaction
and the magnitude of the interaction
that's pretty cool and this enhanced
useful Field view test can be used
particularly to measure that divided
attention in the absence of speed of
processing sort of to to take those two
uh differently and and separate them out
and particularly our 21 tally puzzle
which we hope would correlate to the 21
T game that's out there although we
haven't done the work um can be used to
measure the same thing that it's
enhanced use of fuel of you is
measuring
so uh a dissertation is not a singular
activity and I owe uh a massive de of
gratitude to my committee and everyone
else really if your picture isn't up
here it should be I thank you um and uh
and and that's and that's all I'm gonna
say thank you very
much and if you wouldn't mind if you
have a question just push the button
that says touch and hold it down
there'll be a red light and that'll mean
you're being recorded posterity
I answered
them I'm sure they were
paying just hold it down there thanks
all right so uh the end goal I guess is
to get the these diagnostic tools into
the houses so that people can
continuously kind of track their own um
skill level with the divided attention
exactly and is it to see if they're
declining over time is it to help them
not decline over time like what's the
the end goal it is and I and I'm glad
you asked that because I didn't have
time to really get into it but um my
mentor Holly Jimson has been working on
a cognitive Health coaching platform for
a while now and in terms of what can you
do uh everybody's declining some people
are declining very slowly so slowly it
looks like they're not declining but
we're all declining and if you can
Target what you're declining on you know
is your vocabulary suffering is your
proprioception suffering you know is
your is your uh ability is your divided
attention suffering then if that if
those data are being taken from your
everyday activities in the home and
being uploaded to some sort of cognitive
health coach perhaps screened by some
automated process you know to deal with
privacy issues or any other issues that
you have then that coach can say hey
here are some tests here are some t
tasks that you might want to do to help
uh with your issues in language or your
it looks like you're having trouble with
your sit to stand ability let's work on
that today or something like that so
that's the sort of platform that we're
going for here and that's the sort of
thing that's going to keep people in
their homes longer and be scalable you
know to to a to a large population like
we're we're looking at coming down the
PIP really soon you so thanks that's
excellent excellent
point
um I think it's well known that humans
typically keep track of like three to
seven objects have you looked at um I
guess how the number of objects you've
sort of put in as distractors Compares
with
performance wow that's an interesting
question uh let me see if I can rephrase
it
to indicate my understanding um so there
has been a lot of uh literature
stating that we can
remember uh somewhere between three and
eight things I think that's right yeah
um and you're asking how that applies to
the number of distractors on the
periphery is that right okay
well uh I hate to just say it doesn't um
but really we're talking about two
different things here so those sorts of
tasks are really memory tasks we're
talking about um for instance I'm going
to read you off a list of things things
and see how you you know can you recall
them instantly can you recall them with
a a sort of a distractor interval right
as opposed to this task which is really
uh either an instant perception task
right did you perceive it or not that's
all I want to know did you perceive it
or a search task and either one of those
is sort of a different process in the
frame so I think the the real
interesting part that you got at which
is is you know does the number of
distractors on the periphery uh affect
the eventual threshold value and it
turns out that it it definitely does and
that's that's key to the whole
experiment so it's a good Insight but I
don't think it really applies to the
three to eight that you're were talking
about Karen you had a question I did um
so you know in my very scientific book
club we read this book called The
middle-aged brain I think is what it's
called and they describe in their um
different ways that people have trouble
with divided attention one of the things
I was curious about you had you did look
at age categories was there anything
unique about the older adult middle-age
and older adults who did
better we haven't looked into that but I
I would definitely like to
um uh so I mean that's that's the the
instant answer is that I don't know but
there were considering the range that we
saw in terms of our measurement of of
divided attention which is the
interaction saw a big range and a lot of
people do see a big range in terms of uh
the oldest old 75 plus um in terms of
measuring their divided attention I and
I I don't know uh what has been
discovered about their their unique
abilities
the it wasn't really an in-depth
qualitative set of surveys that we we
said so I would I would really like to
bring them in again and sort of find out
what their lives have been like to
investigate that but right now we don't
really know other than to say you know
you're equivalent to a 40y old good
job anyone else yes listen I think mine
might be a two-part but related question
so stick with me here so the first one
is you talked about the real world
application when Mike asked about this
being part of a health coaching package
is does that mean that it stays sort of
within the realm of I go to the doctor
when I'm 45 and they recommend that I
get get a health coach from then on do I
get a health coach through the Health
Care system or is it is it like sodoku
which they're selling hot like hot cakes
because they're like sodoku keeps your
brain smart and related to that what age
do you start your Baseline I mean we're
always declining you know pick your age
25 or 30 what age do you start taking
these tests so that you finally have a
good Baseline when you finally go south
well that is an excellent two-part
question and the answer to both of them
is give me $20 a month and I will sign
you up right now um but seriously uh
people are addressing uh all all stages
of this that you listed there are lots
of websites as you mentioned like
Lumosity something like that you can
sign up and you can play things like
Sudoku that will theoretically keep your
brain sharp and that's cool they don't
have a lot of data behind them yet and
that's sort of what we're trying to do
to sort of provide that um there are
other uh tasks like uh posit science
that will come into your community or
your assisted living community and give
you a series of of of uh tasks that are
that are really intense but have been
clinically shown to make a difference in
your uh driving ability your your memory
or your uh I'm not sure they have a
divided attention one I haven't looked
in it a while um but they're terrible
you know they're not games they're not
things that you would want to do they're
like pay attention to the difference
between this these two
tones now did the last one rise now
imagine doing that for two hours a day
for a month it's really not fun but it
works so we want to sort of bridge those
two and bring them into uh something
where someone can sign up um I would
have to defer to Holly to to say how
it's going there are a lot of daunting
problems to say you know partially this
is definitely a medical intervention so
we would like to get some sort of uh
trained professional and their
compensation to be uh involved in that
uh if you're going to have someone
monitoring this on the other hand yes I
think you and I and everyone in this
room would benefit from having our
baselines taken now and and and science
would definitely benefit from that so we
could see you know the moment that you
started to decline because again we
still really don't know when you start
to decline and when you start to decline
faster versus someone else who is not
declining faster as you saw you know a
lot of the under 50s are really clumped
up in terms of the the global graph why
are some of them moving faster than
others looks like we got a class coming
in Crystal I'll get you later
Liz um this is really about your testing
and as I understand it it was mainly
measuring rather than U improving my
question is we many of us have taken the
test if we took it 10 more more times or
you kept giving it to us every year or
every six months would we get better at
it right and and I'd like to know as
well um certainly you did certainly
there was a learning effect I didn't go
into it here but from the first test
that you took to the last test that you
took you got better overall at each
individual test um but does that uh does
that uh continue over a month or a year
and does it have any application to your
actual divided attention ability those
are the two things you really want to
know and we don't know uh you know sign
up for my next Tas we'll we'll figure it
out thank
you up to
5:13